إنه قرار سهل جدًا بالنسبة لي ،
فهذا هو فريقي
من حيث مسيرتي الكروية
وأديرت مدربًا هنا من قبل ، لذلك لدي
الكثير من المشاعر والمشاعر تجاه
النادي ، فأنا أيضًا شخص عملي للغاية
تعرفه وعندما تصبح  مدير
تدرك أنك لا تدير
النادي الخاص بك وأنك أنقذت
ناديك إلى الأبد ومن الواضح أنني كنت في
مسار مختلف منذ أن تركت تشيلسي
لكنني أعود في الوقت الذي
طلب مني فيه النادي المجيء
وأخذ الدور بالطبع هذا هو
أهم شيء ولكن أيضًا مع الإيمان
بإمكاني القدوم ومساعدة القضية في
هذه الفترة حتى نهاية الموسم ، لذلك
يسعدني الحصول على هذه الفرصة
وأريد أن أكون ممتنًا  من أجل
ذلك للأشخاص الذين قرروا
منحني فرصة ، أنا واثق من
نفسي لدي فهم جيد
للفريق بالطبع لقد عملت مع
الكثير منهم من قبل ولكن أيضًا في
ملعب التدريب
والاستاد والجماهير  ما يريده مشجعو تشيلسي
وسأبذل قصارى جهدي في هذه
الفترة القادمة
لمنحهم ما يريدون من خلال
عملي الشاق.